Roger I'm a big believer in
infrastructure as code all settings for
my system should be in files that are
checked into Source control
yeah that way you always know what's
running in your production environment
many developers use terraform for that
right but terraform is not right for
everyone I've heard that we can do
declarative deployments in Cloud run
without terraform we sure can let's take
a closer look
[Music]
the first thing we'll need is somewhere
to store application image for that we
can use artifact registry and this is
similar to container registry right yeah
artifact registry provides a single
location for storing and managing
different Docker container images select
container registry except with a couple
of extra bells and whistles all right
let me set it up now in my project
from the navigation under cicd I find
artifacture registry
I'll click on create Repository
I'll give it a name my serverless app
I'll choose Docker I'll choose region us
Central one and actually create
once that's done we can submit the first
build of our application now regular
viewers will be familiar with the
command I have here in build
container.sh gcloud builds submit and
this part of the URL here means that the
build container goes into the artifact
registry
now that it's finished we can head over
to Cloud console and see our build
and there it is let's add a tag to it to
make it easier to reference later on
alright next let's deploy it to Cloud
run and once again this is a familiar
command gcloud run deploy
let's see what that looks like in the
console
if you click the service on this list
you can see the progress click the
revisions tab for more info on the
revision that's currently being created
it's all done let's see if it's up and
running
hello London it's working Roger I see
that our service here has one revision
there can be many uh what exactly is a
revision Roger well when you deploy a
new container image to Cloud run or
change the configuration of an existing
service and immutable revision is
created the revision includes what
container image the service should use
and any configurations that you specify
like defining values for your services
environment variables
funny you should say that Roger and the
cloud run service we deployed does
display the value of the city
environment variable and here it is in
the code and that's what we saw a minute
ago when we hit the services URL
now I'll change in the cloud console
I'll click edit and deploy a new version
then scroll down to the environment
variables I'll change the city variable
here to Munich and I'll hit deploy
and there goes it's deploying a new
revision the revision Name by default
will be auto-generated and start with
the service name
once it's finished deploying 100 of our
traffic will be directed towards the
latest revision I see now that was
pretty easy but it doesn't seem more
practical if I wanted to automate this
process when I make updates to my
application
that's right that's where Cloud run yaml
configuration can come in handy let's
jump back into our code by using a yaml
file for our configuration it lets us
manage our Cloud run service
declaratively
declaratively that sounds like
infrastructure as code yep so instead of
making lots of manual changes the yaml
file just describes what the service
should look like aha but I've heard that
some folks use terraform for that
it's the same idea if you're using
terraform stick with that if not this
could do the trick right I shot a few
terraform videos I'll include the links
to them below but regardless of whether
I'm using terraform or this yaml the
idea is that we can check this file into
Source control right
yeah and that's always much better than
having it in a bash script sitting on a
workstation under your desk
this is a very basic yaml configuration
for cloud run service and it will work
just fine if we wanted to deploy a new
service
since we've already deployed our service
let's retrieve the existing yaml for it
I sent you the command to do that did
you get it all right uh running it now
looks like I got a yaml file here let's
open it
as you can see it's a little more than
just a basic file that we just looked at
check out image under the specs section
that's the container image for our
current revision
and remember that environment variable
we updated that's there in the specs
section under n so what would I have to
do here to say hello to Sydney instead
easy
just update the value to Sydney
but since we're changing that value it's
going to be a new revision so we'll need
a new revision name ah and what kind of
a name should I use for this newer
Vision well it can be anything but
remember it has to start with the
service name
we can also leave that line out and
Cloud run will generate a revision name
for us if there are no changes to the
configuration though it won't create a
new revision okay I will take that line
out and let Google pick a name for the
next revision now how do I use this yaml
file to update my cloud run service
the command you'll use is gcloud run
Services replace followed by the yaml
file that you're going to use
this is a different command than the one
we use to deploy a cloud run service got
it I wrote that up in a shell script
here running it now
it finished applying the yaml I'll go to
the services URL here
and it says hello Sydney just like we
expect
we didn't deploy any new code but we did
deploy new settings a value for the
environment variable
revisions are immutable so if either
code or settings change we get a new
revision hey I noticed that 100 of our
traffic is being sent to our latest
revision here
I know I can change my traffic settings
here in the console how about in my yaml
file you can do that by adding a couple
of lines first you'll need the name of
the revisions that you'll want to use
then in the yaml configuration we'll add
an entry to the traffic block
okay I'll make this a 2080 split between
our latest version hello Sydney and
origin before that hello Munich and this
is useful if I want to make a canary
release only some of my users will get
the latest new hello Sydney version and
if there's a bug not all of my users are
exposed to it that's exactly right now
if that looks right to you we can deploy
the update the same way we did before
with gcloud run Services replace
and there it is now our traffic is split
between this legislation and the
previous one and if I refresh the page
in my browser here
I will see Hello Munich most of the time
and hello Sydney some of the time
so let's say this Canary release hello
Sydney contained a bug and we want to
roll back so our users get the old hello
Munich version 100 of the time how would
we do that
we can do that two ways first we can
simply update the traffic section so
that zero percent is going to our broken
revision
or we can rerun gcloud run replace with
a yaml that excludes a traffic split and
deploys our earlier revision
okay I will update the traffic split
here instead of 20 A.D I will make it 0
100 and then I'll run it again
very good now let's check if it worked
uh yep if I refresh my browser window
here
I I get hello Munich every time
all right Roger so far we've only
updated the configuration for our Cloud
run service not the actual code let's
say I want the service to say bonjour
city name instead like this
what would the Yama look like for
deploying this new code
first you would need to build the new
container image all right I'm running
gcloud build submit now
now that we have a new build we should
go to the artifact registry and check it
out
there's our new build it's tagged latest
and created just now
in order to reference this build we can
use the latest tag that it already has
or give it a new tag and use that okay
so we can update our deployment by
updating the container image URL to
include that tag exactly we'll update
the yaml file again except this time
updating the line for image name under
the template spec
there you'll include the tag for the new
build another alternative is to use
images shot to these six digest instead
of the tag that's another way to
reference a particular build
is there anything else we should change
in this XML file
before we deploy this change we should
also adjust the traffic again
with this change a new revision will be
created so the revision indicated by
latest revision will change to bonjour
ah right I will delete this so the new
version get 100 of the traffic next I'll
apply the yaml
looks good now we've checked out the
console again we'll have 100 of traffic
going to our newest revision that we
just deployed
and it's working great
we've seen how yaml files can be used to
describe and deploy Cloud around
services to recap why is that useful
Roger if you keep that yaml file in
Source control you always know what the
latest settings are for your service and
you can rerun them at any time when
things change and you deploy a new
revision of your Cloud run service you
update the yaml file in your repo it's
very clear what it's currently running
in your production environment very nice
Roger let's say someone watching this
video wants to start using declarative
Cloud run deployments with yaml where
would they start
check out the source repo for this
episode if you already have a cloud run
service you can just run gcloud run
Services describe and that will give you
the current configuration in yaml thank
you for guiding us through this Roger
and thank you everyone for watching you
will find links to the code we talked
about in the show notes if you have any
questions for Roger or me or suggestions
for future serverless topics please
enter them in the comments below we read
every single comment until next time
[Music]
foreign